well I'm thrilled because my next guest
is one of my 11 favorite late night
hosts he's of course on CBS he's beloved
Stephen Colbert so good to have you on
my show Stephen thank you Conan now a
lesser man would would fight with you
right now say no no you're on my show
but I've been a host long enough to know
that the host actually does most of the
work so you go right ahead buddy I see
me all the weights are you now mate you
fell into my trap
beautiful judo moves beta furry bond no
hate if we're done now I notice your
you're not wearing a tie Conan no nice
rate see I haven't I'm not wearing a tie
and I see that you've become a Senate
page congratulations thank you very much
thank you very much yeah how are you
handling your isolation I missed the
laughter I missed the joy that I bring
others well what about your show do you
miss that how about you how are you
handling it I miss the audience because
I get all of my value from their praise
yeah you know I have no I have no
self-worth at all
yeah I only exist really in reflection
to them chanting my name so it's been
rough it's been rough times
that's great that your audience chants
your name mine stop doing that about
four years ago when they chant my name
now it's usually as an angry mob so I
envy you thank you very much you are
using state-of-the-art equipment I tuned
in I check out your show you're clearly
and I know my cameras Your Honor I think
a Sony HDC 1704 K those those are
incredible
you look amazing what are you doing and
you have you have an earpiece I don't
have any ear piece look at that I have
no earpiece on my IFB just broke or your
catheter he can't hear me Kenny I can
hear you now I said even though Stephen
that's not our air you clearly had the
Tiffany Network ship in hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of equipment
then it all been boiled in alcohol so
you could have this amazing
camera what are you doing Lyman look at
the crotch sit down it's xdcam HD you're
right yeah exactly you know why cuz I've
been in this business a long time and I
know my camera's uh-huh
yeah I have a satellite truck parked on
my lawn incredible yeah thank you let me
tell you how I did it here wait listen
buddy I did it your way
for the first week we did it I literally
just did everything off of an iPad
balanced on the side of a bathtub with a
bottle of bubble bath to keep it from
tipping in and killing me yes oh don't
tell me I've been in it let me tell you
how I've been doing it we record my show
on a flip phone when the show is over I
put it into a cardboard tube and I put
it in the u.s. mail and it goes to
Turner headquarters in Atlanta that's
how we've been doing it so don't preach
to me with your story of Oh your
hardships you've got a satellite truck
on your lawn it's been years since I saw
a satellite truck and bitter and enraged
can you tell mm-hmm I back off that was
like a topographical map of Mars
now I'm surprised the local morgue let
you borrow their lighting for it okay
okay what do you this is Shecky Colbert
now that I'm everything you tolerate you
know your lovely family are they helping
you do this because I got my son here my
daughter's doing my makeup my wife is a
is a rodeo clown
yeah they're all pitching in my family
will not help me in the least nobody
wants to help me yeah they really don't
think America needs my show they keep
telling me there's plenty of late night
shows out there I keep asking for help
and they say stop it just stop it go
take a nap my son was the cameraman for
one bit that we shot and after the first
take I said I think we need one more
take and he said you get one more and
that's it so so his Union
he's 14 years old and he was like that
is it you get one more
some people are drinking a little too
much during this period and I think it's
fair to ask you are you indulging a
little bit right now you have a hip
flask that I can't see I don't but I do
actually have a bottle of gin in my desk
Wow
is that a bad sign that's a the bad it's
not that you have it it's that you're
hiding it Steven that's the real problem
you know and I've got something equally
cool and sexy which is I have this
little bobble head Abraham Lincoln
kitten well if you pop the top it's rum
that's a picture of my dad right there
when he was in he was in the army uh he
was a captain this is these was docked
agz right there that's he was also he
was an immunologist at the at the
National Institutes of Health actually
he was associate director of the NIH for
algae and infectious disease he was
basically Anthony pouchy this is my
father's father and his wife my
grandmother and yeah just blossoms we're
losing viewers
no no you're shedding viewers like crazy
right now let me tell you story about
this desk let me tell you sorry about
this desk right here I can't wait this
desk belonged to lieutenant Stoney back
in the 1860s and it doesn't matter what
side he fought for it's a long time ago
let's not get bogged down in it okay
this is my this is my wife's family
you're one of the family I'm not
throwing anybody under a bus here let me
guess a quick question did she call it
the Civil War or I bet she calls it the
War of Northern Aggression we just don't
talk about it Conan we don't are you
starting to think the way I'm thinking
which is yes I love my studio I love
having an audience but I'm telling you
there are people on the network level
that are watching these shows and saying
wait a minute that looks really good
why do we need all that other stuff who
needs an Ed Sullivan theatre when you've
got the Stoney desk mm-hmm and some
books behind you
don't you think solve it The Ed Sullivan
Chipotle sounds pretty good little
revenue right there are you exercising
well clearly not I do very little
exercise everything is true it my whole
body is turning into a sort of a white
pudding like a tapioca lovely I'd take
off my shirt if you could handle it if
you could handle the light imbalance
sure I don't think you could well does
put a polarized lens up so we can handle
the solar well I'm sure you have all
that equipment I do I got everything you
know a very jealous of your fancy CBS
equipment we're shooting this right now
with the Hubble telescope yeah actually
we're capturing your image and infrared
great if you could forward that to my
dermatologist so I could just get myself
checked I'd be very happy uh you and I
are both gonna be celebrating our
birthdays I think in a social isolation
yours is April eighteenth mine is May
13th I think you have a shot really I
have a shot at like actually making
physical contact with other human beings
yes I'm being optimistic I like to be a
but you at least have a chance there's
no way we're out of isolation by April
18th which is my birthday so I'd like to
propose that all of America try and
celebrate my birthday on the 18th what
do you want what do you want what's your
shirt size well that's really nice well
I used to be a lot slimmer and I'd say
in the last week and a half I've gained
65 I'll send you a nice I'll send you a
nice shirt it'll fill some time on your
show where you open the present from me
and you have a shirt from me oh you're
gonna fill time on my show yeah how it
is now I hope so because I really need
that so what's your shirt size Conan
answer the question seven sixteen and a
half with a 39 inch sleeve Wow I'm like
an orangutan
you're manspreading by the way I can see
all of you
not on this camera only on your camera
that's what I'm people at home don't
know is that your camera you're getting
the floor show yes but nobody up there
can see it I am seeing everything and my
hat's off to you I'm very impressed
thank you a lot of relationships are
strained right now
husbands and wives not getting along
together yeah how about you how are you
guys but we've never been happier never
been happy everything's great
everything honey would you come in here
she's too happy to come in
she doesn't want just doesn't want to
come in you haven't laid eyes on her in
three days have you I can't remember
what she looks like Conan
how about Liza how are you guys getting
along well Liza and I were doing pretty
well we're doing pretty well there was a
period there where it got bad where I
took lipstick and drew a face on a broom
and I was talking to that for a while
and we actually our marriage flourished
for a while under those conditions the
broom and I we're getting along so well
she swept you off your feet okay
okay really okay anything anything to
fill time Jeff pets Conan I do I have
okay I got like they I have two dogs
would you like to meet my dog I'd like
to meet your dog yes oh here he goes
he's a little sleepy yeah probably been
watching our interview oh there you go
who is though this is Benny and he looks
good yeah yeah how old is Benny eight
and a half months old he's still kind of
a puppy yeah he just yawned in my face
it was it was a huge blow to my ego that
a dog has tired of my high jinks
now I've proved that I have a dog I
don't can you prove that you have a pet
my dogs are I believe out in the yard so
I'd have to leave for a long period of
time I could go and get one of the dogs
and drag it up here you have a photo of
your dog
not here in the room now why would you
question whether or not I have a dog who
would lie about something like that I
have idea who what who would lie about
having a dog yeah yeah sociopaths will
often lie about it to humanize
themselves I don't have a dog I got a
question before we go here Conan have
you ever been mad at Bob Dylan because
I'm furious is Bob I'm furious at Bob
Dylan right why because you know he did
that 17 minute JFK song in response to
coronavirus well I thought it would be a
perfectly lovely thing to do a song
parody of subterranean homesick blues
yeah and and more my head writers wrote
a really funny parody of it and they
have said Dylan say didn't know on
certain terms you may not do that
neutron bomb of a lawsuit and I just
don't think that's nice how old is that
song he's gotten all the juice he's
gonna get out of that Old Stone come on
let the rest of us have a crack at it I
have won Bob Dylan story which is a
bunch of years ago I went to my Bob
Dylan concert and it was before the show
and my good friend and guitarist Jimmy
Vivino said do you want to meet Bob and
I said I'm not ready to meet Bob and he
went let's go and I got shoved into a
room and suddenly people parted and I
was face to face with Bob Dylan and it
was when he had that little mustache
sure a little like a villain
and he looked at me and I said oh uh
hello mr. Dylan and he went I know you
from the TV and just then I was whisked
out of the room and that was my only
contact with Bob Dylan
I know you from the TV he said it just
like that that sounds like the beginning
of a pretty good song actually it should
be one of his songs
what are you doing now I just want to
give you a taste of what America will
never hear yeah okay we're all in the
basement wishing for some medicine I'm
isolating recommended by the government
the man in the cheap gloves GrubHub day
job says he's got a bad cough wants to
get a test swab come on I understand
that song parody his lowest form of
human entertainment but that's damn fine
listen to the
and here I don't want to virus sales you
better Purell the Trump don't work cuz
the foul she makes him grouchy come on
Bob
so you're using good heal a nation no no
you'd have a lot of young people who
didn't know what you were talking about
it's gotta be a cardi B song you've got
it I wouldn't I'm on CBS Conan it's
gotta be dual eepa you know you got to
bring it up you can't be saying hey kids
it's time I took down Bob Dylan that's
I'm not taking him down I'm celebrating
Bob Dylan okay yeah why are you yelling
at me I don't know you're a long way oh
I'm angry I'm angry at Bob Dylan I'm
sorry you've got a guitar over your
shoulder and I don't know I just I'm not
being fair to you when I apologized
Conan are you crying now you look like
you're crying
well Conan yeah again I'm
on your show right now and you're a
guest online yeah how are we gonna
figure out what part of this actually
makes it terror how do you know be fun
so you you get both sides and I get both
sides we edited our way and you edit it
your way and we've and we compare later
you know we're gonna have two completely
different interviews you know it you're
not even gonna be in my version I'm
gonna replace you with stock footage and
you know what it's gonna go viral the
next day I got I know you got to go but
how do you feel about entropy and the
march of time and the fact that even the
most beautiful things in the world
eventually grow old and decay just break
quick answer I find it relaxing it's
relaxing to know that all is nothing it
calms me good good good wow that's a fun
segment good luck with that good luck
with that one you do your edit I'll do
my edit listen we're both doing the best
we can in my think it's at I'm trying
time so what it's nothing compared to
what people are going through we have
those no is there's nothing comparable
people are going through this what we're
going through as celebrities is worse
than what anybody else is going through
I apologize I apologize I forgot my stat
you man I forgot my status Conan you
lost your perspective oh okay goodbye
god bless you I know I'm your hero
take care how do you need me still or no
no no I'm just doing raps you can stay
if you want but I don't want to watch
this [ __ ] I've seen you right back with
more Conan O'Brien we'll be right back
with more Conan O'Brien how is that do
you like that those are awful maybe we
won't be back with more Connor hey hey
everybody we're back with more Conan
O'Brien still their Idol their care I
care show me what it's like to care
about a guest I want to know I'll show
you
okay I don't want to leave Steven but
the network has business to conduct so I
have to go so we're gonna take a break
but when we come back and we will come
back I'm gonna spend more precious time
with Stephen Colbert he means a lot to
me
and I know he does to you well that's
how you care about a guest that's you
care oh there you go okay let me try
that again
hey we're back hey everybody you lucky
people cuz Conan O'Brien is still here
there's an endless supply of Conan
O'Brien he is our one renewable resource
in this country I say we go off oil and
natural gas we just start burning Conan
[Laughter]
congratulations you're now Stone
Phillips
when we return I'll tell you a chilling
story about sitting naked on a hotel
bedspread that's even I'm gonna leave
you in peace no you can't believe the
bits have to keep goodbye